A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
一丝清水将触及你心灵的深处。那些壮丽的蓝色海浪可以推动你向前，也可以抚平你的浮躁。密歇根海岸连着海岸。只需在当下感受这份流动。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流和溪流留下永恒的回忆。快来投身其中，让清水在纯净的密歇根涤荡你吧。请访问 Michigan.org 了解更多新鲜资讯。或访问我们的网站。
In 2003, 17-year-old Brittany Phillips was thrilled when she received a full scholarship to study chemistry at Eckerd College in St. Petersburg, a coastal city in Florida's Tampa Bay region. Her mother, Dr. Maggie Zingman, had attended the same college in the 1970s and excitedly helped her daughter prepare for the interstate move from their hometown of Tulsa, Oklahoma. Brittany was inspired to study chemistry after losing her grandmother to cancer during her senior year of high school and had decided to dedicate her life to finding a cure for the disease. She left for college in August of 2003 and threw herself wholeheartedly into her studies. Brittany was a friendly and trusting young woman who had no problems settling into her new surroundings. She succeeded academically, made new friends and took a part-time job waitressing at a popular seafood restaurant. However, as she neared the end of her first year at Eckerd College, Brittany became increasingly homesick. She was a year younger than her classmates, having started kindergarten a year ahead of schedule and she found it difficult to be away from her loved ones.
2003年，17岁的布兰妮·菲利普斯（Brittany Phillips）得知自己获得了全额奖学金，将前往佛罗里达州坦帕湾地区的沿海城市圣彼得堡的埃克德学院（Eckerd College）学习化学，她为此兴奋不已。她的母亲玛姬·津格曼博士（Dr. Maggie Zingman）在20世纪70年代也曾就读于这所大学，她兴奋地帮女儿准备从她们的家乡俄克拉何马州塔尔萨（Tulsa）跨州搬家的事宜。在高中最后一年因癌症失去祖母后，布兰妮深受启发，决定致力于寻找治愈这种疾病的方法。2003年8月，她出发去上大学，并全心投入到学业中。布兰妮是一个友善、信任他人的年轻女性，她毫无困难地融入了新的环境。她学业有成，结交了新朋友，并在一家受欢迎的海鲜餐厅找到了一份兼职服务员的工作。然而，随着她在埃克德学院第一年的接近尾声，布兰妮越来越想家。由于提前一年上幼儿园，她比同班同学小一岁，这让她觉得很难离开亲人。
She decided to withdraw from Eckerd College and return to Tulsa to continue her studies closer to home. Brittany's mother Maggie and older brother Joshua supported this decision wholeheartedly. They were a close knit trio, with the mother and daughter speaking on the phone nearly every day. Maggie was always Brittany's first point of contact whenever she was struggling or needed advice and she was relieved that Brittany was returning to the comfort of Tulsa. As a concerned mother, she had been worried about Brittany's safety while she was studying interstate. Not only was Brittany younger than her classmates, but she had a particularly youthful appearance and a trusting nature that Maggie feared could make her especially vulnerable. In May 2004, 18-year-old Brittany returned to Oklahoma and enrolled in Tulsa Community College. Her plan was to obtain the relevant transfer grades that would allow her to study chemistry at Oklahoma State University.
她决定退学并返回塔尔萨，以便在离家更近的地方继续学业。布兰妮的母亲玛姬和哥哥约书亚（Joshua）全心支持这个决定。他们是一个关系紧密的铁三角，母女俩几乎每天都会通电话。每当布兰妮遇到困难或需要建议时，玛姬总是她第一个联系的人，得知布兰妮将回到舒适的塔尔萨，她感到松了一口气。作为一个关心女儿的母亲，她一直担心布兰妮在外州求学时的安全。布兰妮不仅比同班同学年轻，而且外表格外年轻，性格单纯，玛姬担心这会让她特别容易受到伤害。2004年5月，18岁的布兰妮回到了俄克拉何马州，并入读塔尔萨社区学院（Tulsa Community College）。她的计划是取得相应的转学成绩，以便能够在俄克拉何马州立大学（Oklahoma State University）学习化学。
After perusing local apartment listings, she found a suitable one-bedroom apartment in a large housing complex called Glen Eagles, which was located at 9407 East 65th Street in Tulsa. Glen Eagles housed multiple blocks of one and two-storey apartment buildings interspersed with car parking facilities and was home to many other students at Tulsa Community College as well as working couples and young families. It was within walking distance of Union High School where Brittany had graduated from just over a year prior, which pleased her as she was already familiar with the area. Brittany and Maggie inspected apartment number 3216 in the 32nd building. All up, the building had 16 apartments across two levels, with eight on the bottom story and eight on the top. Depending on the location of each apartment, access could be gained via either a front or rear entry. Apartment 3216 was situated on the top floor at the end of the building, meaning there were only adjoining neighbors to one side. The interior was small and a little dated, but it had everything Brittany would need for life as a busy student, including a kitchen, small dining area, living room and bathroom.
在浏览了当地的公寓房源后，她在塔尔萨东65街9407号一个名为“格伦鹰”（Glen Eagles）的大型住宅小区找到了一套合适的一居室公寓。格伦鹰小区有多个一两层高的公寓楼群，其间穿插着停车设施，住着许多塔尔萨社区学院的学生以及工作夫妇和年轻家庭。它距离布兰妮一年多前刚毕业的联合高中（Union High School）步行可达，这让她很高兴，因为她对这一带已经很熟悉了。布兰妮和玛姬查看了32号楼的3216号公寓。整栋楼共有16套公寓，分为两层，底层8套，顶层8套。根据每套公寓的位置，可以通过前门或后门进入。3216号公寓位于顶楼的最东端，这意味着它只有一侧有邻居。内部空间虽小且略显陈旧，但它拥有布兰妮作为一名忙碌学生生活所需的一切，包括厨房、小餐厅、起居室和浴室。
The bedroom even featured a walk-in wardrobe and floor to ceiling bay windows that opened onto a small balcony. The front door, which was accessible from the rear of the building, had a small dent in it, but the landlord assured Brittany they would have it repaired and the rest of the apartment appeared to be in good condition. Being a safety conscious mother, Maggie researched the area online and found that the crime rate there was lower than the state average. She also ran a check for sexual predators in the neighborhood. Concluding that it would be a safe and convenient place to live, Brittany handed over her deposit and signed the lease. Brittany quickly settled back into life in Tulsa. Brittany quickly settled back into life in Tulsa. She attended classes at college 16 hours a week and secured a part-time job as a waitress at a nearby Applebee's restaurant.
卧室甚至还有一个步入式衣帽间和一个通往小阳台的落地飘窗。正门可以从大楼后方进入，上面有一个小凹陷，但房东向布兰妮保证会将其修复，公寓的其他部分看起来状况良好。作为一个对安全非常敏感的母亲，玛姬在网上对该地区进行了调查，发现那里的犯罪率低于全州平均水平。她还查阅了该社区的性犯罪者名单。在断定这是一个安全且方便居住的地方后，布兰妮付了押金并签署了租约。布兰妮很快在塔尔萨恢复了生活。布兰妮很快在塔尔萨恢复了生活。她每周去学院上16个小时的课，并在附近的一家苹果蜂（Applebee's）餐厅找到了一份兼职服务员的工作。
It didn't take long for her to make friends and she soon became close with a group of female students who took turns hosting study groups at their respective homes. Brittany warmly welcomed her friends and their partners to her apartment and enjoyed playing the role of host. Every weekend, she made the two-hour round trip to visit her mother Maggie at her home in the small Oklahoma town of Chandler, where Maggie worked as a psychologist and counselor at a maximum security women's prison. In Tulsa, Brittany soon began dating. Ever since she was little, Maggie had nicknamed her Pretty Brittany on account of her long curly blonde hair, wide eyes and infectious dimpled smile. She was five foot two inches tall with a petite frame and fresh face and her natural beauty had landed her some occasional modeling work. The combination of her good looks and kind nature ensured Brittany was never short of admirers. As she was the type of person who didn't like turning anyone down, Brittany attracted a fair share of undesirable boyfriends, some of whom were physically and verbally abusive towards her.
她没花多长时间就交到了朋友，很快和一个女学生群体亲密起来，大家轮流在各自的家里举办学习小组。布兰妮热情地欢迎她的朋友和伴侣来到她的公寓，并享受扮演女主人的角色。每个周末，她都会驱车两小时往返于俄克拉何马州小镇钱德勒（Chandler）的家中看望母亲玛姬。玛姬在钱德勒的一所最高安全级别女子监狱担任心理学家和辅导员。在塔尔萨，布兰妮很快开始约会。从小时候起，玛姬就因为布兰妮那一头长长的卷曲金发、大大的眼睛和迷人的酒窝微笑而昵称她为“漂亮布兰妮”。她身高五英尺两英寸，身材娇小，面容清秀，天生丽质为她赢得了一些偶尔的模特工作。她出众的外表和善良的性格相结合，确保了布兰妮从不缺乏爱慕者。由于她是那种不喜欢拒绝任何人的人，布兰妮吸引了相当大一部分不受欢迎的男朋友，其中一些人对她进行过身体和言语上的虐待。
At one stage, she went on a date with a security guard who she described to her mother as creepy and strange. Despite saying she didn't want to see him again, the security guard continued pursuing Brittany until she eventually had to block his number. Maggie was relieved when Brittany started dating a nice young man whom she brought to Chandler for a visit. On the afternoon of Monday, September 27, 2004, Brittany was suffering from seasonal allergies that caused her to feel unwell and irritable. This was an ongoing health issue and she went to the Urgent Care Medical Center where she sat in the waiting room for several hours before leaving without seeing a doctor. Frustrated, she called her mother for advice. Maggie told her not to worry and that she would book an appointment for Brittany to see a doctor in Chandler when she came to visit on the weekend. Brittany agreed, telling her mother she had an evening class to attend and would then go straight home to bed.
有一段时间，她和一个保安约会，她向母亲形容这个人毛骨悚然、奇奇怪怪。尽管布兰妮说不想再见到他，但这个保安还是不断纠缠她，直到她最终不得不拉黑了他的号码。当布兰妮开始和一个被她带到钱德勒拜访的 nice 的年轻男子约定时，玛姬松了一口气。2004年9月27日星期一的下午，布兰妮正遭受季节性过敏的折磨，这让她感到身体不适和烦躁。这是一个长期存在的健康问题，她去了紧急医疗中心（Urgent Care Medical Center），在候诊室坐了几个小时后，没看医生就离开了。她沮丧地打电话向母亲征求意见。玛姬告诉她不要担心，并表示当她周末来访时，会为布兰妮在钱德勒预约看医生。布兰妮同意了，并告诉母亲她晚上有一节课要上，然后就会直接回家睡觉。
The pair ended the call as they always did, telling each other, I love you. Brittany then drove to pick up a friend for their class at Tulsa Community College's South Campus. On the way into the class, she ran into her brother Joshua who was also studying at the campus and the two had a brief conversation. After class, at approximately 9.45pm, Brittany dropped her friend home and then drove the short distance back to her apartment. The next day of Tuesday, September 28, Brittany didn't show up to her scheduled classes. Her friends noted this as highly unusual as she was a dedicated and punctual student but they assumed she must still be feeling unwell. That same day, Maggie tried to call Brittany but her phone rang out and eventually went to voicemail. Maggie left a message asking her daughter to return her call.
两人像往常一样结束了通话，互相说了句“我爱你”。接着，布兰妮开车去接一位朋友，准备去塔尔萨社区学院南校区上课。在上课的路上，她遇到了同样在该校区学习的哥哥约书亚，两人进行了简短的交谈。下课后，大约晚上9点45分，布兰妮将朋友送回家，然后开车返回她那不远处的公寓。第二天，即9月28日星期二，布兰妮没有出现在她预定的课程中。她的朋友们认为这非常不寻常，因为她是一个专注且守时的学生，但他们猜测她一定还是身体不舒服。同一天，玛姬试图给布兰妮打电话，但她的电话一直无人接听，最终转入了语音信箱。玛姬留下一条留言，请女儿给她回电话。
On Wednesday, September 29, Brittany was once again absent from her classes and still hadn't returned Maggie's call. Maggie phoned again and left another voicemail. Although it was unusual for the mother and daughter to go a few days without speaking, it did occasionally happen. So Maggie tried to reassure herself that Brittany was likely just busy and would return the call in due course. When Brittany still hadn't shown up to any of her classes by Thursday, September 30, her friends began to worry. At 9pm that evening, Maggie called Brittany but for the third time in as many days, the call went unanswered. She left a third voicemail, this time asking Brittany to call her back immediately as she was starting to become very concerned. Brittany's friend Emma, not her real name, decided to check on Brittany herself.
9月29日星期三，布兰妮再次缺课，并且仍未给玛姬回电话。玛姬再次打电话并留下了另一条语音信箱。尽管母女俩几天不说话是不寻常的，但这偶尔也会发生。因此，玛姬试图让自己安心，认为布兰妮可能只是太忙了，会在适当的时候回电话。当9月30日星期四布兰妮仍未出现在她的任何课堂上时，她的朋友们开始担心起来。当晚9点，玛姬给布兰妮打电话，但连续第三天，电话无人接听。她留下了第三条语音信箱，这次要求布兰妮立即给她回电话，因为她开始变得非常担忧。布兰妮的朋友艾玛（化名）决定亲自去看看布兰妮。
Emma's father was a district attorney with a background as a police officer so she called him as she made her way up the stairs to Brittany's apartment and explained the situation. When Emma reached the front door, she knocked but there was no response. She tried the door handle and was surprised to find that it was unlocked. She pushed it open at crack but her father, who was still on the phone, warned her against going inside. Instead, he offered to send a police officer around to perform a wellness check. The dispatch officers arrived at the apartment just before 10pm. Inside the bedroom, alongside the bed, they found Brittany's lifeless body lying on the floor, facing away from the bed head. It was immediately obvious that her death was the result of a homicide, with marks on her neck indicating she had been strangled.
艾玛的父亲是一名具有警察背景的地区检察官，因此她在走向布兰妮公寓的楼梯时给他打电话，并解释了情况。当艾玛走到前门时，她敲了门，但没有任何回应。她试了试门把手，惊讶地发现门没有锁。她把门推开了一条缝，但仍在通话中的父亲警告她不要进去。相反，他提出派一名警官过去进行一次健康检查。巡警在晚上10点前不久到达了公寓。在卧室里，他们发现布兰妮毫无生气的尸体面朝远离床头的方向躺在床边的地板上。很明显，她的死是一起凶杀案，她脖子上的痕迹表明她曾被勒死。
She was wearing a sleeveless top and underwear but it appeared as though she may have been redressed into this outfit. Investigators were dispatched to the apartment while the crime scene was quickly established and Brittany's body was transported to the medical examiner's office for further investigation. In the early morning hours of Friday, October 1, an officer from the Chandler County Sheriff's Department was sent to Maggie's home to deliver the news. When she opened the door, the officer told her bluntly, You need to call the Tulsa police. Your daughter has been murdered. Assuming the authorities must have Brittany confused with someone else, Maggie got straight into her car and drove the 65 miles southeast to Tulsa. When she arrived at the Glen Eagles complex, she found Brittany's apartment filled with police officers. An officer advised that Brittany was deceased and had been identified using the photo on her driver's license.
她穿着一件无袖上衣和内衣，但看起来她可能是被重新穿上了这套衣服。调查人员被派往公寓，同时犯罪现场迅速建立起来，布兰妮的尸体被运送到法医办公室进行进一步调查。10月1日星期五清晨，钱德勒县治安官办公室的一名警官被派往玛姬家传达这个消息。当她打开门时，警官直言不讳地告诉她：“你需要给塔尔萨警方打电话。你的女儿被谋杀了。”玛姬以为当局一定是把布兰妮和别人搞混了，便直接上了车，向东南行驶了65英里来到塔尔萨。当她抵达格伦鹰小区时，她发现布兰妮的公寓里挤满了警察。一名警官告知布兰妮已经去世，并通过她驾照上的照片进行了身份确认。
Devastated and in shock, Maggie left for the medical examiner's office in the hope of being able to see her daughter one last time. Tulsa homicide detective Jeff Felton and a team of local officers were assigned to Brittany's case. They scoured her apartment and quickly uncovered a wealth of forensic evidence. Alongside the location where Brittany's body had been found, there lay a small tower that looked like it had been used by the killer in an attempt to clean up. A pale purple pillowcase was also nearby and quickly attracted the detective's attention as it didn't match any of the other bed linen in the apartment. This indicated it may have been brought there by the assailant. What appeared to be a urine stain was found on the bed sheet and a miniscule speck of blood was found on the wall leading out of the bedroom. The towel, pillowcase and sheet were taken into evidence for further testing.
悲痛欲绝、处于震惊之中的玛姬前往法医办公室，希望能最后一次看女儿一眼。塔尔萨凶杀案侦探杰夫·费尔顿（Jeff Felton）和一队当地警官被指派负责布兰妮的案子。他们搜查了她的公寓，并迅速发现了大量的法医证据。在发现布兰妮尸体的地方旁边，放着一条看起来像是被凶手用来试图清理现场的小毛巾。附近还有一条浅紫色的枕套，很快吸引了侦探的注意，因为它与公寓里的任何其他床单都不匹配。这表明它可能是凶手带到那里的。床单上发现了疑似尿渍的痕迹，通往卧室外的墙壁上发现了一小点血迹。毛巾、枕套和床单被作为证据收存以进行进一步检测。
In the bedroom and living room, all of the flyscreens had been removed from the windows, amounting to four screens in total. Each of these were dusted for fingerprints. Marks on the bedroom wall indicated that Brittany had put up a struggle in the attack, but aside from this, everything in the apartment appeared to be in place and it didn't look like anything had been stolen. There were no signs of forced entry, which led police to consider that Brittany may have known her attacker and willingly let them inside. They speculated that after the murder, the killer may have then removed the flyscreens to make it look like someone had broken in to conduct a random attack. Alternatively, they may have accessed the apartment from another entry point, perhaps even lying in wait for her to return home. It was presumed that after the attack, the assailant had left via the front door, which explained why it was unlocked when Brittany's friend came upon the scene. At the medical examiner's office, a post-mortem revealed Brittany had been killed sometime between arriving home at 9.45pm on Monday, September 27 and 8 o'clock the next morning of Tuesday, September 28.
在卧室和客厅里，所有的防蝇纱窗都被从窗户上拆了下来，总共四个纱窗。每一个纱窗都被提取了指纹。卧室墙上的痕迹表明布兰妮在袭击中进行了反抗，但除此之外，公寓里的所有东西似乎都井然有序，看起来没有任何东西被偷。没有强行闯入的迹象，这让警方认为布兰妮可能认识她的袭击者，并自愿让他们进屋。他们推测，在谋杀之后，凶手可能取下了纱窗，使其看起来像是有人入室进行随机袭击。或者，他们可能是从另一个入口进入公寓，甚至可能一直在埋伏等她回家。据推测，袭击发生后，凶手是从前门离开的，这就解释了为什么当布兰妮的朋友来到现场时，门是没有锁的。在法医办公室，尸检显示布兰妮是在9月27日星期一晚上9点45分回家到第二天9月28日星期星期二早上8点之间的某个时候被杀害的。
This meant she had laid deceased in her apartment for approximately three days before being found. The faint outline of thumbprints were detected around her neck, indicating the killer had likely strangled her using their bare hands. A rape kit determined that Brittany had been sexually assaulted, but there were insufficient amounts of semen to extract a DNA profile. It appeared as though the rape had taken place after she had been rendered unconscious, but small traces of blood found beneath her fingernails, indicated she had fought her attacker until the very end. Unfortunately, investigators were unable to extract a DNA profile from the blood under her nails. Maggie wasn't allowed to see Brittany at the medical examiner's office and had to wait until she was ready for burial. Her body and face had been covered by a thin towel, and Maggie was advised not to look underneath. Instead, she gently stroked Brittany's hair and set a final goodbye the same way she had always farewelled her daughter, by tracing a fingertip down her covered forehead to the end of her nose.
这意味着她在被发现之前，已经在公寓里去世大约三天了。她的脖子周围检测到了淡淡的拇指印轮廓，表明凶手很可能是用双手勒死了她。强奸套件确定布兰妮曾遭受性侵犯，但精液量不足以提取DNA图谱。强奸似乎发生在她失去知觉之后，但在她指甲下发现的小血迹表明，她与袭击者搏斗到了最后一刻。不幸的是，调查人员未能从她指甲下的血迹中提取出DNA图谱。玛姬不被允许在法医办公室看望布兰妮，必须等到她准备好下葬。她的身体和脸被一条薄毛巾盖住，玛姬被建议不要掀开看。相反，她轻轻抚摸着布兰妮的头发，并以她一贯向女儿道别的方式做最后告别——用指尖顺着她被遮住的前额滑到鼻尖。
On Monday, October 4, Brittany's funeral was held at the Temple Israel in Tulsa on what would have been her 19th birthday. Afterwards, her loved ones proceeded to the Rose Hill Cemetery to lay her to rest. Brittany's obituary, lovingly penned by Maggie, read, A gift has been taken back. On October 4, 1985, your bright eyes opened to the world, and on this day, 19 years later, your eyes closed for the last time. My little girl, with long blonde curls, you were taken too soon. Your youth and aged wisdom are now locked inside. You were the smiling, spinning, dancing pony princess.
10月4日星期一，布兰妮的葬礼在塔尔萨的以色列圣殿（Temple Israel）举行，这本该是她19岁的生日。之后，她的亲人们前往罗丝希尔公墓（Rose Hill Cemetery）将她安葬。布兰妮的讣告由玛姬深情撰写，上面写道：“一份礼物被收回了。1985年10月4日，你明亮的眼睛向世界睁开；而19年后的今天，你的眼睛最后一次闭上了。我的小女孩，带着长长的金色卷卷发，你被带走得太早了。你的青春和超龄的智慧现在被锁在里面。你是那个微笑着、旋转着、跳舞的小马公主。”
You were the young woman who wanted to research ways to heal. You loved deeper than many, and hurt twice as hard. You touched all that ever met you. We all will ache with your loss, for there was so much you had to give. My little pretty, pretty, one last time I say, Remember my smile and kisses, my arms wrapped tightly around you, keeping you safe inside. In this way, I hold you forever. As Brittany's loved ones mourned her sudden and tragic loss,
“你是那个想要寻找治愈方法的年轻女性。你爱得比许多人更深，痛得也加倍剧烈。你触动了所有曾经遇见你的人。我们所有人都会因你的离去而感到痛苦，因为你有那么多东西要给予。我可爱的宝贝，最后一次我对你说：记住我的微笑和吻，我紧紧环抱你的双臂，将你安全地护在怀里。就这样，我永远拥抱着你。”正当布兰妮的亲人们为她突然而悲惨的离去而悲痛时，
Detective Felton and his team worked tirelessly on the case. Brittany's death was the 38th homicide in Tulsa that year, but one of the few that involved sexual assault, and the pressure was on for police to make a quick arrest. The amount of forensic evidence left at the scene gave them hope that the case would be solved quickly, but the fingerprints that had been detected on the window screens were incomplete and couldn't be matched to a suspect. However, it was determined that the speck of blood found on the wall leading out of Brittany's bedroom
费尔顿侦探和他的团队在该案上进行了不懈的努力。布兰妮的死是塔尔萨那一年的第38起凶杀案，但却是少数几起涉及性侵犯的案件之一，警方面临着迅速破案的压力。现场留下的巨额法医证据让他们对迅速破案抱有希望，但窗纱上检测到的指纹是不完整的，无法与嫌疑人匹配。然而，据确定，从通往布兰妮卧室外的墙壁上发现的那小点血迹
had come from an unknown person, and forensic experts were able to use it to establish a DNA profile. Relieved at this news, Maggie thought that it wouldn't be long before her daughter's killer was in prison. She told a reporter from Tulsa World News that once he was caught, she wanted the perpetrator to spend the rest of his life behind bars, as death would be an easy way out. She said, quote, I am hoping they find this person, although I know it will not bring Brittany back.
来自一个未知的人，法医专家能够利用它建立DNA图谱。听到这个消息，玛姬感到很宽慰，她认为女儿的凶手很快就会锒铛入狱。她告诉《塔尔萨世界报》（Tulsa World News）的一名记者，一旦他被抓获，她希望凶手在监狱里度过余生，因为死刑太容易了。她说：“引述一下：我希望他们能找到这个人，尽管我知道这不会让布兰妮回来。”
Working on the theory that Brittany knew her killer, police obtained mouth swabs from her friends, family and neighbors, as well as maintenance workers from the Glen Eagles complex who may have had access to her apartment. The young man she had recently started dating was also tested and questioned. Each DNA sample was compared against the suspect's profile, but no matches were found. The DNA search was extended to Brittany's classmates at both Tulsa Community College and Eckerd College, as well as acquaintances who'd had contact with Brittany in the past.
基于布兰妮认识凶手的理论，警方获取了她的朋友、家人和邻居的口腔拭纸，以及可能接触过她公寓的格伦鹰小区的维修工人的口腔拭纸。她最近开始约会的那个年轻人也接受了测试和盘问。每个DNA样本都与嫌疑人的图谱进行了比对，但没有找到匹配项。DNA搜寻范围扩大到了布兰妮在塔尔萨社区学院和埃克德学院的同学，以及过去曾与布兰妮有过接触的熟人。
Not a single match was made, leading investigators to extend the testing to local persons of interest with a history of sexual assault and violent crimes. Maggie told police about the date Brittany had been on with the security guard that had left her feeling uneasy and tense. The security guard was tracked down but refused to give a DNA sample. Police obtained a court order that required him to comply, however, his DNA wasn't a match to the suspect's and with no other evidence to link him to the case,
没有一个匹配成功，这导致调查人员将测试范围扩大到当地有性侵犯和暴力犯罪史的重点人员。玛姬向警方讲述了布兰妮曾和那个让她感到不安和紧张的保安约会的事。那个保安被找到了，但拒绝提供DNA样本。警方获得了要求他配合的法院命令，然而，他的DNA与嫌疑人的DNA不匹配，并且没有其他证据将他与此案联系起来，
he was ruled out of the investigation. The suspect's DNA was entered into CODIS, the national database used by the Federal Bureau of Investigation to store and analyze DNA. At the time of Brittany's murder, CODIS contained more than 2 million offender profiles, but none matched the killer's sample. Nevertheless, investigators were hopeful that a hit may be generated in the future. The Tulsa Police Department developed a behavioral profile
他被排除了调查。嫌疑人的DNA被录入了CODIS，即联邦调查局（FBI）用于储存和分析DNA的国家数据库。在布兰妮被谋杀时，CODIS包含超过200万名罪犯的DNA图谱，但没有一个与凶手的样本相匹配。尽管如此，调查人员仍希望将来能有匹配结果。塔尔萨警察局制定了一个行为图谱，
and deduced that the killer may have worked in the public service sector and regularly traveled the I-35, I-44 or I-40 highways for work, as these provided cross-country access. He was the type of person who likely stayed up late and often went out during odd hours of the night. He found it difficult to control his emotions and liked to inflict pain on others or himself, both in everyday life and sexually.
并推断凶手可能在公共服务部门工作，并且为了工作经常往来于I-35、I-44或I-40号州际公路，因为这些公路提供了跨国交通。他可能是那种经常熬夜、经常在深夜古怪时间外出的人。他发现自己很难控制情绪，并且喜欢在日常生活中以及性方面给自己或他人施加痛苦。
While he may have previously been outgoing, since Brittany's murder, he had likely become quiet and closed off from family and friends. THE DETECTIVE Considering there were so many other tenants within the Glen Eagles complex, one of the most pressing questions for detectives was how the killer managed to gain access to Brittany's apartment undetected. No witnesses had reported any suspicious activity,
虽然他以前可能很外向，但自布兰妮被谋杀以来，他可能已经变得沉默寡言，与家人和朋友疏远了。侦探：考虑到格伦鹰小区内还有那么多其他租户，侦探们最迫切的问题之一是凶手是如何在神不知鬼不觉的情况下进入布兰妮的公寓的。没有目击者报告任何可疑活动，
nor seeing anyone lurking around the building or attempting to break in. Likewise, no one had been seen leaving the apartment in the early morning hours of Tuesday, September 28. During a search of Brittany's residence, one officer noticed that the ceiling in the walk-in wardrobe contained an access point to the attic. Sliding the manhole cover aside, he hoisted himself into the attic
也没有看到任何人在这栋楼周围潜伏或试图闯入。同样，也没有人在9月28日星期二清晨看到有人离开公寓。在对布兰妮的住所进行搜查时，一名警官注意到步入式衣帽间的吊顶包含一个通往阁楼的通道。他把人孔盖推到一边，把自己拉进阁楼，
and realized that the upstairs space was shared by four apartments on the top floor of the complex. Theoretically, this meant that Brittany's killer could have accessed the attic via any of the other three top floor apartments and then lowered himself into her apartment via the manhole in her wardrobe, lying in wait for her to return. This theory would explain why there were no signs of forced entry and why no one was seen breaking into the apartment.
并意识到楼上的空间由小区顶楼的四套公寓共用。理论上，这意味着布兰妮的凶手可以通过其他三套顶楼公寓中的任何一套进入阁楼，然后通过她衣帽间的人孔降落到她的公寓里，潜伏着等她回来。这个理论可以解释为什么没有强行闯入的迹象，也没有人看到有人闯入公寓。
Another possibility was that Brittany's attacker had managed to hoist themselves up to the bedroom balcony and then entered via the bay windows. Although it would have been an awkward manoeuvre, it would be possible if they were of tall stature. However, gaining entry in this fashion would have required the bay windows to have been left unlocked, which was unlikely given that Brittany was very safety-conscious.
另一种可能是，布兰妮的袭击者设法爬上了卧室的阳台，然后通过飘窗进入。尽管这是一个别扭的动作，但如果他们身材高大，这是可能的。然而，以这种方式进入需要飘窗没有上锁，考虑到布兰妮非常有安全意识，这是不太可能的。
Additionally, it wouldn't have been an easy feat for the attacker to climb onto the balcony without drawing attention. Another lead emerged when the police learnt that the previous tenants in Brittany's apartment were involved in drug dealing. The dent that had been in her front door when she moved in had been caused during one of the frequent altercations that occurred whilst the dealers were living there.
此外，袭击者要爬上阳台而不引起注意并非易事。当警方得知布兰妮公寓的前租户卷入毒品交易时，另一个线索浮出水面。她搬进来时前门上的凹痕是在毒贩住在那里时发生的一次次频繁争吵中造成的。
In one instance, gang members had also broken into the apartment. Investigators considered the possibility that the gang members returned to retaliate against the previous tenants, only to find Brittany there instead. This line of inquiry was explored, but police soon concluded that the previous incidents at the apartment weren't related to Brittany's murder in any way. As the weeks passed by,
在一次事件中，帮派成员甚至闯入了公寓。调查人员考虑了帮派成员回来报复前租户的可能性，结果却发现里面只有布兰妮。这条调查路线得到了探索，但警方很快得出结论，公寓以前的事件与布兰妮的谋杀案没有任何关系。随着时间的推移，
no suspects or major leads were identified. In the early stages of the investigation, the DNA of over 1,000 individuals was tested against the perpetrators with no successful matches. What police initially thought would be a quick investigation with a swift arrest was turning out to be a complete mystery. Locals were outraged by Brittany's murder and the time it was taking to solve the case.
没有确定嫌疑人或重大线索。在调查的初期，对1000多人的DNA进行了测试以比对凶手，但没有成功匹配。警方最初认为这将是一次迅速破案的快速调查，结果却变成了一个完全的谜团。当地人对布兰妮的谋杀案以及破案所花费的时间感到愤怒。
Tulsa crime reporter Laurie Fulbright recounted that in all her years on the job, it was rare that an innocent 18-year-old who wasn't involved in any high-risk behaviour, such as drug dealing or sex work, had been murdered so callously. A couple of months into the investigation, forensic experts examined the bedsheet
塔尔萨犯罪记者劳里·富尔布莱特（Laurie Fulbright）回忆说，在她从事这份工作的多年里，一个没有参与任何高风险行为（如毒品交易或性交易）的无辜18岁女孩被如此残忍地谋杀，这是罕见的。在调查进行几个月后，法医专家检查了从布兰妮公寓拿走的床单，
taken from Brittany's apartment and discovered that what was initially thought to be a urine stain was in fact semen. A DNA sample was extracted, revealing that the DNA from the semen sample was a match to the DNA from the blood sample on the wall. This gave investigators an even stronger profile for the suspect. In order to keep the case in the spotlight,
并发现最初被认为是尿渍的东西实际上是精液。提取了DNA样本，显示来自精液样本的DNA与墙上血样中的DNA相匹配。这为调查人员提供了更强的嫌疑人图谱。为了让此案保持在聚光灯下，
Brittany's mother Maggie conducted interviews with as many media outlets as possible. She contacted various national crime shows, such as America's Most Wanted and the Investigation Discovery Channel in an attempt to have Brittany's story shared, but her requests were continuously rejected. One popular television program told Maggie
布兰妮的母亲玛姬尽可能多地接受了各家媒体的采访。她联系了各种全国性的犯罪节目，例如《全美通缉令》（America's Most Wanted）和探索调查频道（Investigation Discovery Channel），试图分享布兰妮的故事，但她的请求屡次遭到拒绝。一个受欢迎的电视节目告诉玛姬，
that her daughter's death was too boring a story to turn into an episode and that it simply didn't have enough of a hook to cover. The police continued to question those close to Brittany and obtained DNA swabs from individuals with even a loose association to her, but no new leads emerged and no matches were identified.
她女儿的死是一个太无聊的故事，无法拍成一集，而且根本没有足够的吸引力来报道。警方继续盘问接近布兰妮的人，并从与她只有松散联系的个人那里获取了DNA拭子，但没有出现新的线索，也没有确定匹配项。
With no information to go on, the case soon went cold. As the months continued to pass with no new leads, Maggie reached out to the Carroll-Sund Carrington Memorial Reward Foundation for assistance. The foundation was established by the parents of Carroll-Sund, who was murdered along with her teenage daughter Julie-Sund and their traveling companion Sylvina Palosso
由于没有线索可查，该案很快变成了冷案。随着几个月过去依然没有新的线索，玛姬向卡罗尔-桑德·卡林顿纪念悬赏基金会（Carroll-Sund Carrington Memorial Reward Foundation）寻求帮助。该基金会由卡罗尔·桑德的父母设立，卡罗尔·桑德于1999年在加利福尼亚州约塞米蒂国家公园（Yosemite National Park）附近与她的十几岁女儿朱莉·桑德（Julie-Sund）以及他们的同行伴侣西尔维娜·帕洛索（Sylvina Palosso）一起被谋杀。
near Yosemite National Park in California in 1999. It aimed to provide financial rewards to assist law enforcement in locating missing people and bringing violent criminals to justice. The foundation agreed to help Maggie and offered a $5,000 reward for any information leading to the arrest and conviction of Brittany's killer within a six-month timeframe.
其旨在提供经济奖励，以协助执法部门寻找失踪人员并将暴力犯罪分子绳之以法。该基金会同意帮助玛姬，并提供5000美元的悬赏金，用于奖励在六个月内提供线索导致逮捕并定罪布兰妮凶手的人。
The Crime Commission also added $1,000 to the reward pool. On August 16, 2005, a press conference was held to announce the reward money, during which Maggie said, quote, When we have children, for the first few minutes after they are born, we think, what if? What if? But it is too hard to think about something happening to them. She made an impassioned plea for anyone with information
犯罪委员会还在悬赏池中增加了1000美元。2005年8月16日，举行了一场新闻发布会以宣布悬赏金，期间玛姬说：“引述一下：当我们有了孩子，在他们出生的头几分钟里，我们会想，如果呢？如果呢？但很难想象他们身上发生什么事。”她发表了激烈的呼吁，呼吁任何有线索的人
to put themselves in her shoes and not to hesitate to contact the police. The announcement of the reward money generated a few new tip-offs, but none provided any useful leads, and the one-year anniversary of Brittany's murder came and went with no developments in the case. In February of 2006, Maggie reached out to an outdoor advertising company
设身处地为她着想，不要犹豫联系警方。悬赏金的宣布产生了一些新的线索，但没有一个提供有用的线索，布兰妮遇害一周年纪念日来来去去，案情没有任何进展。2006年2月，玛姬联系了一家户外广告公司，
who agreed to feature Brittany on one of their billboards. To maximize public awareness, the billboards would be relocated to different high-traffic areas around Tulsa every three months for a 12-month period. The billboard featured a photo of Brittany, along with the heading, a murderer remains on the streets of Tulsa and a number decor with information.
该公司同意在他们的一个广告牌上展示布兰妮。为了最大限度地提高公众意识，广告牌将在12个月内每三个月轮流搬到塔尔萨周围不同的高流量地区。广告牌上有布兰妮的照片，以及标题“一个凶手仍然在塔尔萨的街头逍遥法外”和一个带有信息的号码。
It was initially erected on the corner of the I-244 Expressway and Utica Avenue, a busy stretch of road in Tulsa. Hopeful that the billboard would generate new leads, the Carroll-Sund Carrington Memorial Reward Foundation agreed to extend the timeframe within which the $5,000 reward money could be claimed. Maggie was cautiously optimistic, but once again the days turned into months
它最初竖立在I-244高速公路和尤蒂卡大道（Utica Avenue）的拐角处，这是塔尔萨一条繁忙的路段。由于希望广告牌能产生新的线索，卡罗尔-桑德·卡林顿纪念悬赏基金会同意延长可以领取5000美元悬赏金的时间范围。玛姬保持着谨慎的乐观，但日子再次变成了月份，
without any promising leads. In September 2007, as the third anniversary of Brittany's death was approaching, the pale purple pillowcase found at the crime scene was displayed to the public at a local news conference. Although Brittany's was the only DNA detected on the pillowcase, Detective Belton explained that the killer may have taken the item to her apartment as a makeshift bag
没有任何有希望的线索。2007年9月，随着布兰妮忌辰三周年的临近，在犯罪现场发现的那条浅紫色枕套在当地的一场新闻发布会上向公众展示。尽管在枕套上只检测到布兰妮的DNA，但贝尔顿侦探解释说，凶手可能把这个物品带到她的公寓作为临时包，
and had accidentally left it behind. He said he had been hesitant to release the description of the pillowcase earlier in case it prompted the killer to throw out any matching linen, therefore destroying evidence. Nearly three years on, he urged the public to think back to September 2004 and recall if they had a boyfriend or roommate who was missing an unbranded pale purple pillowcase
并无意中将其落在了后面。他说，他早些时候一直犹豫是否要公开发布枕套的描述，以防它促使凶手扔掉任何相匹配的床单，从而销毁证据。近三年过去了，他敦促公众回想2004年9月，回忆他们是否有男朋友或室友丢了一条没有品牌的浅紫色枕套，
that had some light bleach staining at one end. This announcement generated no new leads, prompting police to consider whether the pillowcase may have belonged to Brittany after all. When the three-year anniversary came and went with no breakthroughs, Maggie stood on the street near Brittany's apartment, handing out flyers in an attempt
一端有一些轻微的漂白剂污渍。这一声明没有产生新的线索，促使警方考虑这个枕套究竟是否属于布兰妮。当三周年纪念日来去毫无突破时，玛姬站在布兰妮公寓附近的街道上，分发传单，试图
to raise awareness about her daughter's case. She was frustrated by the constant disinterest of national media outlets and had decided to publicise Brittany's case herself. In October of 2007, Maggie had her Toyota RAV4 SUV professionally painted in Brittany's favourite colours, pink and purple,
提高人们对她女儿案件的认识。她对国家媒体长期以来的漠不关心感到沮丧，并决定亲自宣传布兰妮的案件。2007年10月，玛姬将她的丰田RAV4 SUV专业喷涂成布兰妮最喜欢的颜色——粉红色和紫色，
with images of butterflies dancing through swells of colour. Printed in bold, capitalised font along the driver's side of the car were the words, Caravan to Catch a Killer, next to several images of Brittany. Inside the car, Maggie set up framed photos of Brittany alongside some of her favourite childhood toys.
并印有蝴蝶在色彩波涛中起舞的图像。汽车驾驶员一侧印有醒目的大写字体“Caravan to Catch a Killer”（追捕凶手大篷车），旁边是布兰妮的几张照片。在车内，玛姬摆放了布兰妮的照片，旁边是她童年最喜欢的玩具。
Although she barely had enough money to support herself, Maggie set off across the northeast USA in her eye-catching SUV. For three weeks, she travelled through small towns, stopping wherever she could to tell Brittany's story and successfully attracted attention from local media. Upon her return home and to work, Maggie set about saving enough money to tour her Caravan to Catch a Killer
尽管她几乎没有足够的钱养活自己，但玛姬还是开着她那辆引人注目的SUV踏上了美国东北部的旅程。三周里，她穿梭于小镇之间，无论走到哪里都停下来讲述布兰妮的故事，并成功吸引了当地媒体的关注。回到家和工作岗位后，玛姬着手攒钱，以便带着她的“追捕凶手大篷车”在东南各州巡回演出。
through the southeastern states. At the time of Brittany's murder, just 15 states in the USA took DNA samples from offenders upon their arrest. The remaining 35 states, including Oklahoma, only took DNA samples at the time of conviction. This allowed many sex offenders to slip through the cracks, as some victims retracted their statements
在布兰妮被谋杀时，美国只有15个州在逮捕时从罪犯身上采集DNA样本。其余的35个州，包括俄克拉何马州，只在定罪时才采集DNA样本。这使得许多性侵犯者得以漏网，因为一些受害者撤回了他们的陈述，
or failed to testify before a conviction could be made, often due to shame and fear of retribution. Maggie believed that if DNA samples were required to be taken from offenders at the time of arrest, Brittany's killer would have been identified right away. She began working in close contact with legislators and police to campaign for the laws to be changed in Oklahoma, telling the Tulsa World newspaper, quote,
或者在定罪前未能作证，通常是由于羞耻和对报复的恐惧。玛姬认为，如果在逮捕时要求从罪犯身上采集DNA样本，布兰妮的凶手就会立刻被识别出来。她开始与立法者和警察紧密合作，开展在俄克拉何马州修改法律的竞选活动，她告诉《塔尔萨世界报》：“引述一下，
We can't bring Brittany back, but I am going to use her name and her story to change these laws, so maybe this does not happen to someone else. In response, civil rights advocates argued that obtaining DNA upon arrest was an unconstitutional breach of privacy rights. Another problem when it came to identifying the killer's DNA was that a huge backlog of DNA samples collected from rape test kits
我们无法让布兰妮回来，但我将利用她的名字和她的故事来修改这些法律，所以也许这不会发生在其他人身上。”作为回应，民权倡导者认为在逮捕时获取DNA是对隐私权的违宪侵犯。在识别凶手DNA时遇到的另一个问题是，从强奸测试套件中收集的大量DNA样本积压如山，
were yet to be analyzed and added to the CODIS database. This was a nationwide problem, as funding cuts meant more pressing issues took precedence. In Oklahoma alone, thousands of DNA samples taken from rape victims were still untested, with some dating back as far as a decade. There were no laws requiring that testing be done
尚未得到分析并添加到CODIS数据库中。这是一个全国性的问题，因为资金削减意味着更紧迫的问题占据优先地位。仅在俄克拉何马州，从强奸受害者身上采集的数千个DNA样本仍未经过测试，其中一些可以追溯到十年前。没有任何法律要求进行测试，
or that untested samples were kept, which led to a large number of rape test kits being discarded by law enforcement agencies. In April of 2008, Maggie embarked on her second caravan to catch a killer tour, with Britney's pink cowboy hat riding alongside on the passenger seat. She travelled a total of 4,200 miles throughout America's southeast, giving 17 news interviews across nine states,
也没有要求保留未测试的样本，导致执法机构丢弃了大量的强奸测试套件。2008年4月，玛姬踏上了她的第二次“追捕凶手大篷车”巡回之旅，布兰妮的粉红色牛仔帽陪伴在副驾驶座上。她在美国东南部总共行驶了4200英里，在9个州进行了17次新闻采访，
while also campaigning for Oklahoma's DNA testing laws to be changed. Maggie was overwhelmed by the kindness of strangers who were willing to listen to her story, with some even donating money for fuel so she could continue her journey. She also met other parents whose children had been murdered and began building up a support network for families to share stories of their loved ones. Maggie spent the next few years setting out across the country on more caravan to catch a killer tours whenever time and finances allowed.
同时还为改变俄克拉何马州的DNA检测法律进行竞选。玛姬被陌生人的善良所淹没，他们愿意倾听她的故事，甚至有人捐钱买燃料，以便她能够继续她的旅程。她还遇到了其他孩子被谋杀的父母，并开始建立一个支持网络，供各家庭分享他们所爱之人的故事。只要时间和财务允许，玛姬在接下来的几年里一直在全国各地进行更多的“追捕凶手大篷车”巡回之旅。
In 2011, lawmakers concluded that collecting DNA from a suspect who was not a convicted felon went against the Fourth Amendment rights of unlawful search and seizure. They also believed it contradicted the fundamental constitutional right of the presumption of innocence until proven guilty. Disappointed by the outcome, but undeterred, Maggie pressed on. The following year,
2011年，立法者得出结论，从并非被定罪重罪犯的嫌疑人身上收集DNA违背了第四修正案关于非法搜查和扣押的权利。他们还认为这违背了未经证实有罪前无罪推定的宪法基本权利。对结果感到失望但并未气馁，玛姬继续前行。第二年，
the Supreme Court determined that collecting DNA upon arrest was not an invasion of privacy and had nothing to do with being innocent until proven guilty, as DNA was nothing more than a forensic tool akin to collecting fingerprints. Following this, more states across the country started passing laws that required DNA to be collected from suspects at the time of arrest for certain crimes. By 2014, as the 10-year anniversary of Brittany's death passed, Maggie wrapped up her 12th caravan to catch a killer tour
最高法院裁定，在逮捕时采集DNA并不侵犯隐私，也与“未经定罪前被视为无罪”无关，因为DNA不过是一种类似于采集指纹的法医工具。在此之后，全国越来越多的州开始通过法律，要求对犯下特定罪行的嫌疑人在被捕时采集DNA。到2014年，随着布里特妮逝世十周年的过去，玛吉完成了她第12次“乘房车抓凶手”巡回宣讲活动
and was more determined than ever to stop the case from going cold. In May 2016, thanks in part to Maggie's tireless campaigning, Oklahoma became the 29th state to sign a bill that required DNA to be collected at the time of arrest for suspects of rape and certain violent crimes. As the votes were read aloud, the senators gave Maggie a standing ovation. During a subsequent interview with Fox 23 News at Brittany's gravesite, Maggie said, quote, People tell me I'm brave, or people tell me I could never do this,
并且比以往任何时候都更加坚定，绝不让这起案件变成悬案。2016年5月，部分归功于玛吉不懈的奔走呼吁，俄克拉荷马州成为全美第29个签署法案的州，该法案要求在强奸及某些暴力犯罪嫌疑人被捕时采集DNA。随着投票结果被大声宣读，参议员们全体起立为玛吉鼓掌。在随后接受福克斯23台在布里特妮墓地进行的采访时，玛吉说，引述如下：“人们告诉我我很勇敢，或者人们告诉我我永远做不到这一点，
but I have no choice. I sort of feared that if we find her killer, we're going to find out that he was arrested numerous times, that he came through the system, and that because we didn't take the DNA then, that he was out there doing it again. She said she hoped the new laws would enable perpetrators to be captured quickly before they had the chance to commit further crimes.
但我别无选择。我有点担心，如果我们找到了凶手，我们会发现他曾多次被捕，他曾通过司法系统，而就是因为我们当时没有提取DNA，他才得以逍遥法外，继续作案。”她表示，希望新法律能够让作案者在有机会实施进一步犯罪之前就被迅速抓获。
An investigator from the Oklahoma State Bureau of Investigations DNA Lab said that if the law had been passed two years prior, 14 murders and 25 sex crimes could have been prevented. She told Fox 23 News, quote, We're talking about bad crimes, murder, assault, child sexual assault, child physical assault. Obtaining DNA upon arrest casts a wider net where we capture those people maybe when they first offend,
俄克拉荷马州调查局DNA实验室的一名调查人员表示，如果这项法律能早两年通过，本可以阻止14起谋杀案和25起性犯罪。她告诉福克斯23台，引述如下：“我们谈论的是恶性犯罪，谋杀、攻击、儿童性侵、儿童身体虐待。在逮捕时获取DNA可以撒下一张更大的网，让我们可能在这些人初次犯罪时就抓住他们，
instead of when they offend the fifth or sixth time. In mid-2017, a state audit into the backlog of DNA test kits revealed that the Tulsa Police Department had more than 3,000 untested kits dating back to the early 1990s. Due to lack of funding, the department concentrated on testing the more recent kits first, as there was a higher chance the perpetrator would be prosecuted
而不是等到他们第五次或第六次犯罪时。”2017年中期，一项针对DNA检测试剂盒积压情况的州级审计显示，塔尔萨警察局拥有3000多个自20世纪90年代初以来一直未检测的试剂盒。由于缺乏资金，警局集中精力优先检测较新的试剂盒，因为凶手被起诉的可能性更高，
and there weren't enough resources to process the backlog. This meant that if Britney's killer had committed another sexual crime, which police believed was highly likely, his DNA could be sitting on a shelf untested. In early 2018, nearly 14 years after Britney's murder, advances in DNA phenotyping technology allowed for an image of the prime suspect
而且没有足够的资源来处理积压的案件。这意味着，如果布里特妮的凶手犯下了另一起性犯罪（警方认为这种可能性极高），他的DNA可能正躺在架子上无人检测。2018年初，在布里特妮遇害近14年后，DNA表型分析技术的进步使得人们能够利用从其血液和精液中提取的图谱，生成主要嫌疑人的肖像。
to be generated using the profile obtained from his blood and semen. Although DNA phenotyping doesn't provide an exact match, it can accurately predict the person's genetic ancestry, eye and hair color, complexion, face shape, and even whether or not the person has freckles. Although the testing is expensive, MAGI organized for the leading DNA phenotyping laboratory in the country, Parabon Nanolabs, to create the image
虽然DNA表型分析不能提供完全匹配的身份，但它能够准确预测此人的遗传祖源、眼睛和头发颜色、肤色、脸型，甚至这个人是否有雀斑。尽管检测费用高昂，玛吉还是安排了国内领先的DNA表型分析实验室——帕拉邦纳米实验室（Parabon Nanolabs）来制作这幅图像，
in the hopes it would result in further tips from the public. The DNA phenotype revealed that the killer was a Caucasian male of European ancestry. He had either blonde or brown hair and blue or green eyes, with a sprinkling of light freckles over his nose and cheeks. Upon seeing the image, MAGI's first thought was that he was handsome and someone Britney would have been attracted to. The image was circulated via the media
希望这能带来更多来自公众的线索。DNA表型显示，凶手是一名欧洲血统的白人男性。他有一头金发或棕色头发，蓝眼睛或绿眼睛，鼻子和脸颊上点缀着浅浅的雀斑。看到这幅图像时，玛吉的第一反应是他长得很帅，是布里特妮会产生好感的那种人。这幅图像通过媒体广为流传，
and MAGI had it enlarged and placed on the hood of her caravan to catch a killer vehicle. This way, the picture could attract attention while MAGI wouldn't be forced to look at it every time she got in and out of her car. Within the first two days of its release, the image generated approximately 200 tips from members of the public who thought they recognized the man.
玛吉还将其放大，印在了她的“乘房车抓凶手”汽车的车前盖上。这样一来，这张照片既能吸引注意力，又免得玛吉每次上车下车时都不得不去盯着它看。在图像发布后的头两天里，它大约收到了200条来自公众的线索，这些人都认为自己认出了这个人。
In addition to the phenotype image, the Oklahoma State Bureau of Investigation employed another unconventional method in Britney's case. A photograph of Britney, along with a brief explanation of her murder, was featured on the second deck of cold-case playing cards released amongst Oklahoma prisons. These decks featured a different cold-case on each card, with the aim of prompting discussions between inmates as they played,
除了表型图像之外，俄克拉荷马州调查局还在布里特妮的案件中采用了另一种非常规方法。布里特妮的照片以及对她谋杀案的简短说明，被印在了俄克拉荷马州监狱发行的第二副悬案扑克牌上。这些扑克牌每张都印有不同的悬案，旨在促使犯人在打牌时展开讨论，
which in turn might result in new information being reported. The cards did generate a few tips from prisoners, but investigators were also mindful that inmates may have been hesitant to discuss Britney's case, given that she had such a youthful appearance and sexually motivated crimes against youth so generally frowned upon in the prison community. Britney's murder has plagued the city of Tulsa.
这反过来可能会带来需要报告的新信息。这副牌确实从囚犯那里征集到了一些线索，但调查人员也注意到，囚犯们可能对讨论布里特妮的案件有所顾忌，因为她外表十分年轻，而针对年轻人的性动机犯罪在监狱社群中通常是为人所不齿的。布里特妮的谋杀案一直困扰着塔尔萨市。
In 2014, criminologist Melissa Anderson began examining the case for a criminal justice class she toured at Union High School, which both she and Britney had attended. Her classes dissected the details of the case, studying everything from the layout of Britney's apartment to conducting interviews with Maggie and members of the Tulsa Police Department.
2014年，犯罪学家梅丽莎·安德森（Melissa Anderson）开始在一门刑事司法课程中研究这起案件，这门课程是在联合高中（Union High School）巡回教学时开设的，她和布里特妮都曾就读于该校。她的课堂剖析了案件的细节，从布里特妮的公寓布局到对玛吉以及塔尔萨警察局成员的采访，进行了全面研究。
One student had a relative who resided in the Glen Eagle's apartment complex, which had since been renamed to the Somerset Apartments. The layout of his relative's apartment was a mirror image of Britney's, and the student soon learned that the shared attic space was still easily accessible via the walk-in wardrobe. This meant that the tenants could still gain access to any of the adjacent apartments through their attic manhole.
有一名学生的亲戚住在格伦鹰公寓综合体（Glen Eagle's apartment complex，该小区后来更名为萨默塞特公寓）。他亲戚的公寓布局与布里特妮的完全呈镜像对称，这名学生不久便了解到，通过步入式衣橱依然可以轻松进入共用的阁楼空间。这意味着租户仍然可以通过阁楼的检修孔进入任何相邻的公寓。
When the phenotype image became available, the students combed through old yearbooks looking for anyone who carried a resemblance, but were unsuccessful in finding a match. Studying the case hit home for the students, who were struck by the fact that Britney used to walk down the same hallways as them every day. One student remarked to Tulsa's news on 6,
当表型图像公布后，学生们翻阅了旧年鉴，寻找任何长相相似的人，但未能成功找到匹配对象。研究这起案件对学生们触动很深，他们深受震撼，因为布里特妮曾经每天都走在和他们相同的走廊里。一名学生对塔尔萨6号新闻台说道：
quote, She was like one of us. Although no new developments have arisen from their efforts, Maggie was touched by the amount of energy the students put in. She formed a special bond with Melissa Anderson and many of the class members, who would show up to see her off when she embarked on her caravan to catch a killer tour,
引述如下：“她就像我们中的一员。”尽管他们的努力没有带来任何新的进展，但玛吉被学生们投入的精力深深打动了。她与梅丽莎·安德森以及许多班级成员结下了特殊的纽带，每当她踏上“乘房车抓凶手”巡回之旅时，他们会赶来送行，
then welcome her home when she returned. By 2019, Britney's case was being overseen by the head of Tulsa's cold case homicide department, Detective Eddie Majors. The alleged Golden State killer, Joseph DiAngelo, whose then unsolved crimes were covered in episode 53 of Case File, had been arrested using familial DNA and investigators were hopeful
在她归来时又欢迎她回家。到2019年，布里特妮的案件由塔尔萨未破凶杀案部门负责人埃迪·梅杰斯警探（Detective Eddie Majors）负责监督。涉嫌为金州杀手的约瑟夫·迪安杰洛（Joseph DiAngelo）——其当时尚未侦破的罪行曾在《案件档案》（Case File）第53集中被报道——是通过亲缘DNA被逮捕的，调查人员对此抱有希望，
that the same technique could identify Britney's killer. At Parabon Nanolabs, the DNA found at Britney's crime scene was run through Jetmatch, an online database that connects to other genealogy websites to compare DNA samples from more than one million individuals. It wasn't expected they would find an exact match, as it was highly unlikely that the killer would voluntarily submit his DNA to a genealogy site.
认为同样的基因技术可以识别出布里特妮的凶手。在帕拉邦纳米实验室，在布里特妮案发现场发现的DNA被输入了Jetmatch，这是一个在线数据库，它连接到其他族谱网站，以比较来自一百多万个人的DNA样本。他们并没有期望能找到完全匹配的DNA，因为凶手自愿将自己的DNA提交到族谱网站的可能性微乎其微。
However, there was a chance it might detect the DNA of one of his relatives to help narrow the search. To the surprise of investigators, the DNA belonging to the prime suspect in Britney's murder not only detected a familial link, but a direct match. Around the same time, someone also recognized the person in the phenotype image
然而，仍有机会检测到其亲属的DNA，从而帮助缩小搜寻范围。令调查人员吃惊的是，布里特妮谋杀案主要嫌疑人的DNA不仅检测出了亲缘关系，而且直接找到了匹配对象。大约在同一时间，也有人认出了表型图像中的那个人，
and reported their name to police, confirming him to be the same person identified via the genealogy database. The individual was quickly apprehended and interrogated by the Tulsa police, while Maggie was informed that the prime suspect had finally been identified. However, after 15 years searching for Britney's killer
并向警方报告了他的名字，证实他就是通过族谱数据库识别出的同一个人。此人很快被塔尔萨警方逮捕并审讯，同时玛吉被告知主要嫌疑人终于被找到了。然而，在经过15年寻找布里特妮凶手的过程后——
using the DNA found at the crime scene as the number one lead, it was determined that the semen sample found on Britney's bedsheet and the blood sample found on her wall didn't belong to the killer at all. The DNA had been left behind by the boyfriend of one of Britney's friends after she had allowed the couple to sleep in her bed one night. Considering that his DNA hadn't been on Britney's body,
这期间一直将案发现场发现的DNA作为第一线索——调查结果表明，在布里特妮床单上发现的精液样本和在墙上发现的血液样本根本不属于凶手。这些DNA是布里特妮的一位朋友的男友留下的，此前该朋友曾让这对情侣在她的床上睡过一晚。考虑到他的DNA不在布里特妮的身体上，
as no profile could be developed from the sample underneath her fingernails, there was nothing to tie this man to the crime. The man was interrogated by police for hours until they were satisfied he wasn't involved in Britney's murder. He was then free to leave. Maggie was devastated with the hopes she had held for the past 15 years dashed in an instant. She told local news station KTUL
因为在她指甲下方提取的样本无法生成DNA图谱，所以没有任何证据将此人与该罪行联系起来。此人被警方审讯了数小时，直到警方确信他没有参与布里特妮的谋杀案。随后他被释放。玛吉感到心碎欲绝，她过去15年里一直怀有的希望在瞬间破灭。她告诉当地新闻台KTUL，
that hearing the news was nearly as hard as hearing of Britney's death as it effectively put the investigation back to square one. The phenotype that had narrowed down the physical characteristics of the suspect was no longer valid, meaning the perpetrator could be of any ethnicity or appearance. After receiving this significant blow, Detective Majors has spent countless hours going back through Britney's case file.
听到这个消息几乎和听到布里特妮的死讯一样艰难，因为它实际上将调查工作又打回了原点。那个缩小了嫌疑人身体特征范围的表型分析结果不再有效，这意味着作案者可能是任何种族或外貌。在遭受了这一沉重打击后，梅杰斯警探花费了无数个小时重新翻阅布里特妮的案卷。
He's re-interviewed persons of interest who had previously been ruled out on account of their DNA not matching that found at the crime scene. This is no easy task, as many of these individuals have since moved from Tulsa and are difficult to track down. Adding to this frustration is the fact that despite changes to Oklahoma's law, state funding has not yet been allocated to allow for DNA to be taken from offenders
他重新讯问了那些此前因DNA与案发现场发现的不符而被排除嫌疑的重点关注人员。这绝非易事，因为其中许多人自那以后已经搬离了塔尔萨，很难追踪到他们的下落。更令人沮丧的是，尽管俄克拉荷马州的法律发生了变化，但州政府尚未拨出资金来允许在嫌疑人
at the time of arrest. As of early 2020, this means that DNA is still only being recorded at the time of conviction. However, DNA profiles continue to be added to the CODIS database daily, which now houses more than 13 million profiles. Detective Majors believes Britney's killer likely has three or more other victims, none of whom are from the same location. He probably moved around, striking in different areas at different times.
被捕时提取DNA。截至2020年初，这意味着DNA仍然只能在定罪时被记录。然而，DNA图谱每天都在继续被添加到CODIS数据库中，该数据库目前容纳了超过1300万份图谱。梅杰斯警探相信，布里特妮的凶手很可能还有其他三名或更多的受害者，且这些受害者都不在同一个地方。他可能四处流窜，在不同的时间在不同的地区作案。
One theory is that the killer was a truck driver or had another occupation requiring frequent travel and was just traveling through Tulsa at the time of Britney's murder. Even though Maggie was crushed by the loss of the number one lead in the case, she has vowed to continue on her caravan to catch a killer to us until her daughter's murderer is caught and brought to justice. So far, she has traveled a total of 240,000 miles across the 48 states of mainland America and has gone through 20 different vehicles.
有一种理论认为，凶手是一名卡车司机或从事其他需要频繁出差的职业，在布里特妮遇害时恰好途经塔尔萨。尽管玛吉因失去案件的核心线索而心碎，但她发誓要继续她的“乘房车抓凶手”巡回宣讲，直到她女儿的谋杀案告破并将凶手绳之以法。到目前为止，她已经在美国本土48个州总共行程了24万英里，并换用了20辆不同的汽车。
Given the case's recent developments, Maggie intends to revisit the locations of her earlier tours to keep sharing Britney's story and educating the public about the advances in DNA technology. She manages a website dedicated to the case, BritneyPhilipsMurder.net, as well as a Facebook page that provides any updates as they arise. Anyone with information about the case is encouraged to contact Maggie via her website. I remember when I first held Britney in my arms,
鉴于该案最近的进展，玛吉打算重访她早期巡回宣讲过的地方，继续分享布里特妮的故事，并向公众普及DNA技术的最新进展。她管理着一个专门针对该案的网站 BritneyPhilipsMurder.net，以及一个随时提供最新进展的Facebook页面。鼓励任何掌握该案线索的人通过她的网站与玛吉联系。我记得当我第一次把布里特妮抱在怀里时，
the beauty of her sort of angelic face just filled my whole body with love. And as she grew up, she just transformed from this energetic, fearless, young little girl to this energetic, fearless, compassionate, empathetic, young woman who at times was still like a little girl. I mean, I can remember a year before she died where she got upset and it was before she went to school and she just sort of crumbled in my arms. And when she got upset, she would say mommy instead of mom. And I just remember holding her in my arms, both as a child and as a young lady.
她那种天使般面孔的美丽让我的全身都充满了爱。随着她长大，她从一个精力充沛、无所畏惧的小女孩，蜕变成了一个精力充沛、无所畏惧、富有同情心和同理心的年轻女性，有时她看起来依然像个小女孩。我的意思是，我记得在她去世前的一年，她曾感到难过，那是在她去上学之前，她就那样依偎在我怀里崩溃了。当她难过的时候，她会叫“妈咪”而不是“妈妈”。我只记得把她抱在怀里，无论是作为孩子还是作为年轻的淑女。
She became and I feel like both with her beauty because she was very beautiful and her intelligence so much was taken. She was going to be a cancer researcher. She was going to do so much and that's no longer here. And if anyone has a daughter, a child, hug them every day. And if you're filled with empathy from the story, please send your ideas to this podcast or to me or to the Tulsa Homicide Hotline. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她成为了——而且我觉得无论是从她的美貌（因为她非常漂亮）还是从她的智力来看——太多的东西被剥夺了。她本打算成为一名癌症研究员。她本可以做成那么多事情，而这一切都不复存在了。如果任何人有女儿、有孩子，请每天给他们一个拥抱。如果你从这个故事中感受到了同理心，请将你的想法发送给这个播客、发送给我，或是发送至塔尔萨凶杀案热线。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。